it is Linda Lee from the president of
the Law Society she's now chair of voice
and organization which represents
victims out witnesses of a crime Linda
Lee great heavy with us on Sky News
Tonight do you agree with the decision
by the dirt Republic prosecution that
not to charge Lord Anna now I don't I
think it's a betrayal of victims who
have finally placed their trust in the
system only to be told that they will
not have the evidence heard it's very
tricky situation though isn't it because
a public prosecutor has to weigh up
wasting public money on pursuing this
against a man who's that on well against
making sure that justice is done what
would you have done I would have let the
judge decide let the judge decide
whether or not he was fit to plead if he
wasn't fit to plead then the process
would be that the jury would hear the
evidence and not find him guilty or not
guilty but decide whether or not he had
done the acts alleged the judge would
then have a range of orders available
that he could make but at least the
victims would have had their day in
court their chance to put their case
after all these years have been silenced
when evidence was there to support them
they're owed this opportunity I'm afraid
and no matter what the cost to the
public purse we heard there in our
report that there are the options of
legal challenge being looked into at the
moment do you still think it's possible
this could happen and we could see
perhaps or Janet ride in his absence I
hope that the victims will ask the CPS
to review the decision which they're
entitled to do and that the CPS we'll
think again there are other remedies but
those are even more costly and I think
this is something where the CPS should
look again at its decision I understand
why Alison Saunders made the decision
she did but I think in this case there
is compelling evidence to suggest that
that decision should be reversed we
heard left one of the alleged victims or
but Lord Janner and you represent now
victims of crimes how damaging it is it
when something like this happens does it
really impact
perhaps on victims who would otherwise
have come forward about something
absolutely in northamptonshire we've set
up a special helpline for victims of
historic sex abuse and current sex abuse
crimes with the red crisis center they
have specialist counselors who will
assist when people make that first step
because it's very hard for victims to
come forward and they need access to all
sorts of help not just legal help and
it's important that we put right what
has been done that is wrong they deserve
our help and support and we should give
that now they're suffering in silence in
their thousands and it's time that we
put an end to that and when you look at
the way that the CPS has handled cases
like this overall how are they
performing I would not criticize the CPS
overall mistakes have been made in the
past the CPS are trying very hard now to
get it right I just think in this case
they should think again Alison Saunders
has faced a lot of Christians in the
last few weeks and only for this but for
other things as well how she performing
in her role overall is her credibility
being damaged by this I think
unfortunately this decision has has
caused her some damage but it's not too
late to put it right and we were talking
about earlier about the fact that
obviously they've had to weigh up the
decision in the light of the resources
that are available i mean operably
prosecutors suffering because of a lack
of resources and is there impacting
therefore or cases like this the
detriment of public opinion I feel the
justice system as a whole is suffering
because of the lack of resources it's a
fundamental right for people to have
access to the courts and in many
circumstances both in civil and crime
people are not getting access to court
they're not being supported in that
process and we must recognize that
access to justice is as important as
access to other services like health and
education